every year the Mauritius wildlife
organization takes more than 10,000
people on guided tours of the Egret
island nature reserve the flora and
fauna here are almost all unique to
Mauritius the NGO uses its nature trail
to educate the population about
protecting endemic species only five
percent of the island states original
forest remains in the mountain forests
on the main island van saun Flores
studies how the indigenous species
benefit nature forest was really well
preserved in the first place but then
very importantly the invasive alien
plants have been removed as you can see
just behind here dying tree there this
is an invasive plant and you can see
it's been ring Bart at the base and if
you look over there you will see that
this area is very dense because it's
still full of invasive alien plants they
have not yet been removed when you
remove them you have a much more lighted
place that we are in here and as you
look around you here you see a lot of
young plants growing the forest started
generating again the giant bats known as
flying foxes are returning ensuring that
the seeds of their favorite fruits are
scattered across the forest floor the
tall trees that grow from the seeds
protect the undergrowth invasive macaque
monkeys have been removed from the
forest they destroy important plants and
the hatchlings of rare birds the
macaques used to be kept in cages here
Marianne and Owen Griffiths run a
business with them they breed and sell
macaques for animal experimentation most
of the proceeds go to biodiversity
protection projects our challenge is to
help with government with other NGOs
protect the remaining bits of land in
one way of doing it as you've just
alluded to is by up threaten areas and
then put in a conservation program which
means removing the invasive alien
species and helping restore the original
forest
but is it right to sacrifice one animal
to preserve other species opposition is
mounting on the internet and on social
media platforms the organization doctors
against animal experimentation says that
in 2013 hundreds of lab monkeys were
delivered to Germany does it he rely
these animals suffer terribly especially
once they're in the land when they're
subjected to toxicity tests and when
they tortured to death there's no way
any benefit to other species can
counterbalance that John garden but then
saw flora says the griffiths forests are
important for his research into
biodiversity because of the extent hot
air circulation here a lot of extinction
we are ahead of the world in many ways
of studying conservation in Mauritius
gives us a bit of a advance notice of
what's going to happen around the world
the flying foxes can once again hunt for
food in the forests that surely is a
sign of hope in the fight to protect
endemic species here